you ambassador Gordon Sunland the only
first-hand witness to president Trump's
thought process on Ukraine finally
speaks Plus Democrats prep for a debate
Battle Royale I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
the men Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn protect your online privacy
today at expressvpn dot-com / Benton can
we're gonna get to all the news and
there's tons of news today but first let
me explain when things filled chaotic
and do they feel a little chaotic right
now in stock market is doing really well
but there's a feeling that maybe that
might weaken in the near future we don't
know where things are going on the forum
front obviously things are heating up
with China things are heating up with
Iran in the United States the domestic
political situation is unsettled to say
the least
well it might be worthwhile to diversify
at least a little bit into precious
metals it's something that I have done
it's something that I recommend
everybody do gold right now is sitting
at its five-year high and I've been
telling you for years one of these
things that would be smart to do is take
a little bit of your money and put it
into an asset that can't be manipulated
by the central government Birch gold
will have that conversation with you you
can determine if precious metals make
sense to include in your portfolio again
make sense for my portfolio I think it
makes sense for yours as well there's no
obligation you have nothing to lose to
take that first step of just requesting
a free information kit on Gold Birch
gold group has thousands of satisfied
satisfied customers countless five-star
reviews and a plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau
I like the folks at Birch gold group I
trust them I've worked with them for
years
again that A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau speaks better than I can
on it
text Ben - 47 47 47 - requests that free
information kit on gold get yourself
educated to ask all of your questions
and get your answers from Birch gold
that's been - 47 47 47 texts that my
name Ben - 47 47 47 and when you speak
to them be sure to ask what promotions
they are currently offering their big
supporters over to the show over at
Birch gold and you should support them
as well okay so today is the biggest day
in terms of the public hearings that are
taking place regarding the Trump Ukraine
quasi scandal impeachment inquiry the
reason that today is the biggest day is
because the only person who has yet
testified or is planning to testify who
has had a direct conversation with
President Trump testified today and that
be you ambassador
Gordon Sumlin so you'll recall that in
his original testimony Gordon someone
suggested that there was no quid pro quo
or at least that he was told by Trump
that there was no quid pro quo in his
original testimony he suggested that he
had only spoken with President Trump
maybe five or six times since being
appointed ambassador other witnesses
have suggested that that is not true
that in fact it had many conversations
with Gordon Sun
he had also suggested that he spoke
briefly to Trump before traveling to
Ukraine for meetings on July 26th which
is right before Trump was supposed to
speak with President Solinsky in Ukraine
and he had said at the time I do recall
a brief discussion with President Trump
before my visit to Kiev
the call was very short non-substantive
and did not encompass any of the
substance of the July 25th White House
call with ukrainian President President
Vladimir as olenski also he had some
sort of July 26th call with Trump but in
his initial deposition he didn't recall
that right he said he recalled no
discussions with any State Department or
White House official about former Vice
President Joe Biden or his son he said
in his original testimony remember all
these witnesses have given closed-door
testimonies now they're being brought
out into the open he said in his
original closed-door testimony he didn't
recall taking part in any effort to
encourage an investigation into the
Biden's okay then there are other people
who have testified that Gordon Sumlin
had spoken to Trump and that he had been
overheard speaking to Trump there was a
witness named David Holmes who's a
political counsellor at the US Embassy
in Kiev and he testified that he heard
someone speak to Trump after a meeting
with zalenski aides and during that
conversation someone had said he was
gonna call Trump to give him an update
and apparently Holmes said that he heard
the president's voice through the
mouthpiece of the phone and that
President Trump clarified that someone
was in Ukraine and that President
Solinsky quote/unquote loves your ass
apparently that's what he said to
President Trump and then apparently
Trump asked if he was gonna do the
investigation now is any of that
substantive in terms of is any of that
substantive in terms of it did Trump
commit an impeachable offense well we've
known for a while I've been arguing for
a while that in fact it's pretty obvious
that Trump was withholding military aid
in exchange for investigations or I mean
that that part is true the question is
easily withholding of aid for the
investigations illegitimate so what was
the purpose of the investigations were
the investigations designed to bring
down Joe Biden in advance of 2020 or
were the investigations designed to
investigate what happened in 2016
both because Trump is vindictive about
2016 because he's obsessive about 2016
because he feels that he has been given
a raw deal by the media on 2016 which is
true but also because he believes in
conspiracy theories about Ukraine which
are not true because he knows that there
have been credible media reports from
places like Politico
the Ukraine was in fact coordinating
with the DNC to go after Paul Manafort
his campaign chairman for a while that
part's true but also Trump was worried
about CrowdStrike based on bad
information for me too Giuliani my
suggestion for months at this point has
been that President Trump basically
wrapped up all the stuff in a ball on
Ukraine decided he didn't really want to
give aid to Ukraine anyway because he
was always a little bit split on giving
more aid to Ukraine he always felt that
Europeans weren't doing their fair share
he always wondered why the United States
was was spending so much time and effort
in Ukraine and he finally allowed that
to cloud his judgment to the point where
he sat on camera and withhold the
military aid until I get these
investigations and the investigations
are everything that bothers me about
Ukraine up to and including Purisima and
Joe Biden now the way that you would
establish an impeachable offense is if
what you found was that and the
Democrats basically said this right it's
not just me saying this this is the
Democrats setting the standard they
suggest that this was to get Biden right
this is all about Biden all the rest of
this stuff the CrowdStrike stuff the
2016 elections stuff all that stuff is a
ruse really what Trump wanted was to go
get Joe Biden and all the rest of the
stuff he was mentioning these other
investigations having to do with
corruption these other investigations
about about the Ukrainian embassy
coordinating with the DNC in 2016 all of
that was merely a pretext for Trump to
force Ukraine to go get Joe Biden right
that's the case so Gordon Sunland is the
person who theoretically could speak to
that right Gordon Sunland is the guy who
could get on who could get up before
Congress today and he could say right I
talked to Trump Trump said go get the
Biden's and the rest of all this was a
charade that isn't exactly what Gordon
someone said so people are honing in on
the fact that Gordon someone had changed
his testimony his original closed-door
testimony he said he didn't understand
there was a quid pro quo with Trump and
Ukraine now of course he changed his
testimony and he suggested that there
was in fact a quid pro quo with Trump
and Ukraine but it is not clear exactly
whether that quid pro quo was wrong
whether that quid pro quo was it was a
problem so here is what Gordon Sumlin
had to say in his early testimony today
he said he had a bunch of things to say
so he began by explaining that everybody
was in the loop on this like everybody
knew that Trump was basically
withholding military aid in order to get
investigations whatever investigations
means this is clip this is clip 18 he
says
everybody was in the loop it's not like
this was a giant secret with regard to
Ukraine policy you would greatly
appreciate a call prior to Sunday so
that he can put out some media about a
friendly and productive call no details
prior to Ukraine election on Sunday
chief of staff Mulvaney responded I
asked the NSC to set it up for tomorrow
everyone was in the loop it was no
secret
everyone was informed via email on July
19th days before the presidential call
okay so not only did everybody knows as
Gordon someone and everybody at the
State Department new opportunity Mike
Pompeo that President Trump was
manipulating Ukraine policy in order to
achieve investigations so everyone was
in the loop right wasn't it Sunland is
trying to say it wasn't just me it
wasn't me making up this foreign policy
it wasn't like don't don't try to throw
me under the bus right he's got a
problem with the foreign policy I was
not the originator of the foreign policy
I'm not going to be the man who gets
caught in the crossfire here I was doing
the will of the President of the United
States here's someone explaining that
everybody at the State Department knew
clip 19 we kept the leadership of the
State Department and the NSC informed of
our activities and that included
communications with Secretary of State
Pompeo his counselor
Ulrich Breck bull his executive
secretary Lisa Kenna and also
communications with Ambassador Bolton
dr. hill Mr Morrison and their staff at
the NSC they knew what we were doing and
why okay everybody knew right in other
words this was not a giant secret which
you would assume at this point since
half the people on the call that July
25th phone call made complaints now the
wreath and then Sunland continues along
these lines and he says listen the only
reason we were even working with Rudy
Giuliani was at Trump's behalf so if you
think that I was coordinating with
Giuliani excited some sort of side
relationship with Giuliani not gonna
happen so Sunland is trying to achieve a
couple of things with this testimony one
he can't say anything that overtly
contradicts his closed-door testimony
because then he would be charged for
perjury
Republicans would charge him with
perjury - Gordon Sunland does not want
to be the guy who is basically put out
there as he was freelancing the foreign
policy now listen I don't think that
that was a credible accusation in the
first place I think that if anybody had
claimed that Gordon Sungmin was making
up Ukrainian foreign policy on his own
the giant owner to Trump will ended up
his EU Ambassador suddenly an expert on
Ukraine and negotiating with Rudy
Giuliani that was never a credible
defense for the Trump administration
again the only credible defense was the
one that I have presented for Trump
which was an intent based defense right
the no quid pro quo it was a perfect
phone call defense was obviously crap it
was obviously a craft from from very
nearly the beginning right as soon as it
came out that the Ukrainians had found
out pretty soon after the July 25th own
call that military aid was being
withheld to say that there was no quid
pro quo at all was obviously untenable
to suggest that President Trump was in
that the president Trump had engaged in
a perfect phone call on July 25th
obviously was also untenable
the only tenable defense is that
President Trump did not have intent to
go after Joe Biden specifically in
extent in advance of 2020 it was not
about getting Biden it was about all of
his thoughts on Ukraine mashed up
together thrown out there and Ukraine
was supposed to fulfill all of these
concerns that Trump had some of which
were legitimate some which some of which
were based on bad information being
provided by Rudy Giuliani but Sunland is
trying to avoid the it's my fault
routine that I think many in the Trump
administration wanted someone to take
the bullet here and someone ain't gonna
do it so here is someone saying listen
the only reason we were even talking
with Rudy Giuliani is because of
President Trump finally at all times I
was acting in good faith I was acting in
good faith as a presidential appointee I
followed the directions of the president
we worked with mr. Giuliani because the
president directed us to do so we had no
desire to set any conditions we had no
desire to set any conditions on the
Ukrainians okay so there it is him
saying along with members of the other
of the foreign policy team that they
were trying to get Trump they're trying
to pry loose the aide from Trump and it
was not about them freelancing for Rudy
Giuliani or anything it was top down
Trump was the one who was telling him
talk with Rudy Giuliani and then someone
says
Rudy wanted a quid pro quo right the
quid pro quo is a thing that happened
and that Rudy Giuliani's request
obviously amounted to a quid pro quo
here is someone using that phrase quid
pro quo which is different than what he
had said in his closed-door testimony
and then he'd revise write originally he
had said he didn't understand there was
a quid pro quo then he came back and he
said no no actually I got that wrong I
just want to revise this I'm not charged
with perjury I did understand that there
was a quid pro quo even if I didn't
understand the full extent of the quid
pro quo here is someone saying the
Giuliani's requests did amount to a quid
pro quo in the absence of any credible
explanation for the suspension of aid I
later came to believe that the
resumption of security aid would not
occur until there was a public statement
from Ukraine committing to the
investigations of the 2016 elections and
bery smih as mr. Giuliani had demanded I
shared concerns of the potential quid
pro quo regarding the security aid with
Senator Ron Johnson and I also shared my
concerns with the Ukrainians
sunlen then concludes by suggesting that
President Trump said that there was no
quid pro quo right that he what it is
true that he was on the phone with Trump
and Trump had said no quid pro quo we'll
play that for you in just one second
first let's talk about your sleep
quality so let's be real about this it's
hard to get sleep these days
politics is exciting a lot going on it's
probably going on in your life I mean
we're approaching Thanksgiving or
approaching Christmas a lot of stuff
going on a lot of chaos in life well
when you lie down on that mattress don't
you want to be comfortable so why
exactly would you have a mattress they
just picked up at some big box store
that's not made for you he would sleep
personalizes your mattress to you hulex
sleep has a quiz it takes just 2 minutes
to complete it matches your body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you no matter how you sleep
side back hot sleeper whatever helix can
make you it can make what your body
needs just go to helix sleep calm /ban
take their two minutes sleep quiz they
will match you to a customized mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life when I'm on the road I do not
sleep as well because I do not have the
helix sleep mattress which is why I'm
always relieved to be home and get on
that helix sleep mattress for couples
helix can even split the mattress down
the middle providing individual support
needs and feel preferences for each side
they've got a 10 year warranty and you
get to try it out for a hundred nights
at risk-free they'll even pick it up
for you if you don't love it but you're
going to so don't worry about it helix
is offering up to 125 bucks off all
mattress orders for our listeners get up
to 125 bucks off at helix sleep comm
slash Ben that's helix sleep comm slash
man for up to 125 dollars off your
mattress order helix sleep comm slash
man go check them out right now they
really are fantastic mattresses are so
good I go on for my sister for her
wedding I mean they really are fantastic
helix sleep comm slash Ben okay so
Gordon sunland concludes by saying that
Trump did say to him no quid pro quo but
basically I didn't believe him when he
said no quid pro quo and nobody believed
him when he said no quid pro quo here is
someone saying the Trump did say no quid
pro quo but I believe I just asked him
an open-ended question mr. chairman what
do you want from Ukraine I keep hearing
all these different ideas and theories
and this and that what do you want and
it was a very short abrupt conversation
he was not in a good mood and he just
said I want nothing I want nothing I
want no quid pro quo
tell those elinsky to do the right thing
something to that effect
okay so that's what from said but it's
pretty obvious that someone didn't
believe him now there is stuff that
someone said that goes to the key
question right so Democrats the media
they're focusing in on the broader
question which I believe was already
established right and and they're
focusing in on that because the Trump
administration keeps running away from
what it's obviously true right they keep
saying no there was no quid pro quo
perfect phone call okay that was always
an indefensible position it was nearly
always an infant nearly always in the
first couple of weeks it appeared maybe
defensible after that it was it was a
nearly indefensible position saying
there was no quid pro quo is obviously
untrue there was in fact a quid pro quo
and I'm sorry but the defense to be
intellectually honest the defense that
was presented by the Trump
administration which was okay well if
there was a quid pro quo Ukraine got its
aid they didn't give us what we wanted
where's the quid pro quo right the
accusation by Democrats and by people
who don't like Trump the accusation is
that the reason that he changed the
Ukrainian policy and then released the
aid is specifically because this became
a public issue it was embarrassing for
him and so he released the aid because
he had to so he preemptively corrected
the problem before it materialized in
its fullest form right that is the
accusation and so saying that eventually
Ukraine got its aid as sort of like
saying I tried to blackmail somebody it
failed and therefore I'm not guilty for
trying to blackmail somebody
that's not a good defense the only
defense here that makes any sense at all
is the one that I've been presenting
over and over and over again which is
that President Trump again because I
think this is true president Trump has
in his head a bunch of crap and that
bunch of crap about Ukraine can be
listed on a three by five note card and
every time he mentioned anyone mentions
Ukraine he flips to that note card and
he gives you everything on that note
card right he gives you breeze m''e and
he gets you biden and he gives you
CrowdStrike and he gives you twenty
sixteen election interference right
those are the things on his note card
and he's a general predisposition not to
want to give aids Ukraine that is
something that I disagree with him on
but he's the president he's elected I'm
not right so he's the President of the
United States he does get to set foreign
policy even foreign policy with which I
disagree so the question here for
someone is did Trump make clear to you
that he only wanted the Biden's and the
rest of this was a pretext was Trump
using taxpayers dollars to go after a
domestic political opponent or was Trump
using taxpayer dollars in order to pry
anti-corruption concessions out of
Ukraine and information about Ukrainian
interference in the 2016 election and
sunland to Democrats chagrin right this
is the part you're not gonna hear him in
the media today sunlen I knew the
foreign policy everybody knew the
foreign policy we all knew the quid pro
quo was going on but what we were doing
did not appear to be wrong alright
that's the part everybody is going to
ignore here's Gordon Simon clip 17
saying listen I may disagree with the
foreign policy I may have thought Trump
should change it but we didn't think we
were doing anything legally wrong here
if we thought we were doing something
legally wrong wouldn't on it here's clip
17 still given what we knew at the time
what we were asked to do did not appear
to be wrong
third let me say precisely because we
did not think that we were engaging in
improper behavior we made every effort
to ensure that the relevant decision
makers at the National Security Council
and the State Department knew the
important details of our efforts okay
and Gordon Sunland said that as far as
his own conversations with Ukraine he
didn't recall mentioning the Biden's
which makes sense because officials from
Ukraine have said we don't run
hearing from Gordon someone about the
Biden's here's someone saying so if this
whole thing was about Biden's then why
didn't I mention the Biden's cliques at
clip 16 and then on July 26th you
confirm you did indeed have the
conversation with President Trump from a
restaurant and keeve that david holmes
testified about last week is that right
correct
and you have no doubt no reason to doubt
mr. holmes recounting of your
conversation with the president the only
part of mr. holmes recounting that i
take exception with is i do not recall
mentioning the Biden's that did not
enter my mind it was verrry smih in 2016
elections you have no reason to believe
that mr. Holmes would make that up if
that's what he recalls you saying you
have no reason to question idea
III don't recall saying bite I never
recall saying bite okay so he is
obviously contradicting the testimony of
somebody who says he overheard someone
ok so again the Washington Post is
picking up on the fact that the actual
question is a question of intent there's
a piece by Josh taozi today called
Republicans defend Trump as concerned
with Ukrainian corruption but aides tell
a different story but even the piece
basically acknowledges the Democrats
have not made their case so here's what
the Washington Post says some of
president from Salle's have argued that
his motivation for holding up almost
four hundred million dollars in aid to
Ukraine was his deep-seated concern
about corruption and that he needed to
test the new Ukrainian administration's
dedication to rooting it out in
persistent questioning during the house
hearings Republican lawmakers and their
staff lawyer have pressed witnesses to
agree the Ukraine has long had a
corruption problem and to portray
Trump's desire to have Kiev investigate
his political rivals as fitting within
that broader worry representative Jim
Jordan said last week what corruption is
not just prevalent in Ukraine is the
system our president said timeout
timeout let's check out this new guy
while there is widespread agreement that
Ukraine has long struggled with
corruption recent congressional
testimony along with interviews with
officials who worked closely with the
president raised questions about how
much Trump cared about corruption
broadly in Ukraine as opposed to
investigations that stood to benefit him
politically okay now investigations that
stood to benefit him politically is not
the same thing as solely meant to
benefit him politically let me give you
an example so President Trump is very
upset about the idea that the Ukrainians
interfered in the 2016 election forget
Biden for a second he's very concerned
with the idea that the Ukrainian embassy
was coordinating with a woman named
Alexander chalupa who is an emissary of
the Democratic National Committee in
there
attempts to dig up dirt on Trump's
campaign because apparently the
Ukrainian government perceived that the
Trump campaign had been Pro Russia and
so they were very concerned that Paul
Manafort was the one who was influencing
all of this they started funneling
information to the DNC about Paul
Manafort and so Trump's concerned about
all of that and he wants Ukraine to
investigate all of that now is that
relevant to the American public
of course that's relevant to the
American public we just did a two and a
half year investigation into Russian
investigate in Russian interference in
the American election why would it not
be relevant to the American public if
Ukraine interfered in the 2016 election
and coordinated with the DNC in order to
do so you can't have it both ways either
the Moller investigation was a get Trump
effort and relevant or it was based on a
fundamentally true assumption about the
nature of American elections which is
that foreign country should not
interfere if the latter then Trump is
perfectly within his rights
even if motivated by certain vindictive
anger he's perfectly within his rights
to ask whether the Ukrainians were
interfering in the 2016 election so when
the Washington Post draws this false
binary between worrying about Ukrainian
corruption and quote-unquote
investigations that stood to benefit him
politically that's too broad there are
certain things that fall under both
meaning that presumably if it turns out
that the Ukrainians were in fact
targeting Trump in 2016 that might
benefit him politically going into 2020
you know certainly a sway shoes feelings
going into 2020 but is that an area of
relevant political consideration for the
American public of course it is right do
you think that it would have benefited
Democrats politically had they found out
that Trump had coordinated with Russia
in advance of 2016 of course does that
make the inquiry illegitimate on its
face no okay so what the Washington Post
is trying to establish is that president
from generally doesn't care about
corruption he only cares about Ukraine
because it concerns him okay but again
that's too broad that's true but that
does not mean it's illegitimate is true
I'm sorry Trump doesn't care about
corruption in Zambia right Trump isn't
worried about corruption in Mexico per
se Trump isn't worried about corruption
in most places in the world but he was
worried about corruption in Ukraine why
was he worried about corruption in
Ukraine not because of Joe Biden in 2020
but because he was angry over 2016 and
he saw that the Ukrainians were
attempting to target him according to
Politico not according to Rudy Giuliani
Wars or something and the Washington
Post basically acknowledges as much
right the Washington Post says for
former administration officials who
spoke on the condition of anonymity to
describe at private conversations shared
someone's view and said Trump's main
contention was that Ukrainians had quote
tried to take me down in the words of
one former senior administration
official from angrily complained the
official said that they had Hillary
Clinton's email server a reference to an
unfounded theory the Democrats conspired
with Ukrainians to interfere in the 2016
election former envoy to Ukraine Kurt
Volker sunland and other officials said
in testimony that this view is shaped by
Rudy Giuliani the president's personal
lawyer officials said Trump described
Ukraine as a problem because it caused
tensions with Russia and sucked security
money out of the United States Heba
grudgingly approved the military aid in
2017 after being repeatedly pushed by
national security officials okay so that
that's my theory
not the Democratic theory that backs my
theory that Trump was was was sitting
there and and simply mulling over in his
mind and obsessing about 2016 not that
he was attempting to go after Joe Biden
in 2020 okay that Washington Post piece
backs in my case not their case okay in
one second we're going to get to more of
the testimony over the past couple of
days which was all supposed to be
bombshell but turns out in many cases
not really to be Plus we will get to
whether inquiring about Purisima is is
deeply corrupt in some way I'll get to
that in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that as you were driving
into work today you looked around there
are a thousand different kinds of car on
the road and let's say that your car
broke down yet a problem with your car
and you just went to the local auto body
parts shop well would they have the
exact part that they need or would they
give you something generic off-the-shelf
that cost too much money the answer
probably the latter and this is why you
should check out Rock Auto comm they're
a family business they've served Auto
Parts customers online for 20 years go
to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they have everything from
engine control modules and brake parts
to tail lamps motor oil even new carpet
whether it's for your classic or daily
driver get everything you need in a few
easy clicks delivered directly to your
door it's a lot better than going to an
auto parts store wider selection
reliably low prices no waiting in line
for the one person at the desk
who's serving like 10 people at once
instead you through it from your home
the interwebs a fantastic thing best of
all prices at Rocko
are always reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfer as
do-it-yourselfers they've got amazing
selection reliably low prices all the
parts your car will ever need Rock auto
comm go check them out right now
rockauto.com
and see all the parts available while
you're there right shapiro in there how
did you hear about us box so they know
that we saying that helps us that helps
them go check them out Rock Auto calm
again rockauto.com okay so as I say
sunland's testimony is not actually
providing answers to the key question to
the key question which is what exactly
is the intent here right what exactly is
the intent here now again the fact is
that that someone is not really even
testifying as to intent and when he has
testified to incense then the president
that then someone has basically
suggested that the intent was go after
problems in 2016 not problems in 2020
and even in his testimony he basically
suggests the same now all of that can be
based on bad information now all of that
can be based on bad information provided
by Rudy Giuliani president Trump being a
sort of conspiratorial minded dude sent
rudy giuliani over its ukraine to dig
into what happened in 2016 Rudy Giuliani
it appears was feeding him bad
information provided by corrupt
Ukrainians who are now being prosecuted
under the law but that's Trump's fault
there is bad judgment not bad intent per
se right it was it was bad judgment who
trusts Rudy Giuliani's info that does
not mean this was all about getting bite
remember the original accusation is that
Donald Trump used taxpayer dollars in
order to basically bribe the Ukrainians
to give him bad information on Joe Biden
for purposes of the 2020 election not
that he had broad Ukrainian corruption
concerns dating back to 2016 and that he
was using American resources to
investigate that that may have been
motivated by base political concerns but
so is nearly everything in Washington DC
that's not the same as he was
weaponizing a foreign government to go
after a domestic political rival with an
eye toward 2020 and Canada and by the
way who's to say that it's legitimate
for people to ask questions about what
happened with regard to Purisima right
Elise Stefanik for example she's the the
representative Republican representative
who's getting all sorts of press these
days she was talking with lieutenant
colonel Alexander Whitman he was the
Democrat star witness yester
and she asked VIN men about Purisima and
burries me and VIN Minh basically
acknowledges that burries m'a is corrupt
and so if Trump asked about Purisima
what's a legitimate about that
specifically here's the lis Stefanik
going after bin Minh I know that my
constituents in New York 21 have many
concerns about the fact that hunter
Biden the son of the vice president sat
on the board of a corrupt company like
BER yzma the Obama administration State
Department was also concerned and yet
Adam Schiff refuses to allow this
committee to call hunter bite and
despite our requests every witness who
has testified and has been asked this
has answered yes do you agree that
hunter Biden on the board of BER yzma
has the potential for the appearance of
a conflict of interest certainly the
potential yes okay and and by the way
VIN Minh also who is the Democrats star
witness yesterday came in full military
regalia obviously served honorably in
the United States military for 20 years
and stood on that to the cheers of the
media right he was asked specifically
about hunter Biden he said yeah of
course hunter Biden wasn't qualified for
the position he held I mean hunter Biden
has acknowledged that himself here's
ven-ven's saying hunter Biden was not
qualified we talked a little bit about
at your deposition about whether mr.
Biden was qualified to serve on this
board and you know I believe you
acknowledged that apparently he was not
in fact qualified as far as I can tell
he didn't seem to be but like I said I
don't I don't know his qualifications
okay okay so again the questions about
hunter Biden those are not going away
they're not going away and so the fact
that that Trump was concerned about
buries men hunter Biden and wrapping
that all up in 2016 concerns that does
not speak to go get Joe Biden it doesn't
speak to go get Joe Biden specifically
so to go back to sunland's testimony I'm
reading through his entire opening
statement right now there are a few key
sections right he says we all understood
that if we refused to work with mr.
Giuliani we would lose an important
opportunity to cement relations between
the United States and Ukraine so we
followed the president's orders again
that is someone maintaining I'm not the
fall guy here you want to blame somebody
blame Trump but he also says although we
disagreed with the need to involve mr.
Giuliani we did not believe his role was
improper at the time as I previously
testified if I'd known all of mr.
Giuliani's dealings or
associations with individuals now under
criminal indictment I would not have not
have acquiesced to his participation
still given what we knew at the time
what we were asked to do did not appear
to be wrong and he said precisely
because we did not think that we were
engaging in improper behavior we made
every effort to ensure that the relevant
decision-makers at the National Security
Council and State Department knew the
important details of our efforts the
suggestion that we were engaged in some
irregular or rogue diplomacy is
absolutely false so someone is actually
kicking back there against the
accusation being made by the other
witnesses that there was this irregular
channel and that Sunland and vulgar and
and Rick Perry and the president and
Pompeyo they were in this irregular
Channel and then there was the regular
Channel which was all of the career
diplomats the honorable career diplomats
sounds like no everybody knew about this
everybody was in on it everybody
basically acknowledged that it was weird
but nobody thought that this was wrong
at the time and it was only later that
people started to suggest that it was
wrong which gives the idea that this was
in fact politically motivated or at
least could have been politically
motivated from the outset right someone
also acknowledged the Giuliani's
requests were a quid pro quo Giuliani
said that he was expressing the desires
of the President of the United States
and everybody knew the investigations
were important to the President of the
United States and he said in July and
August 2019 we learned that the White
House had also suspended security aid to
Ukraine and everybody was upset about
all of this he shared his concerns with
Ron Johnson and with the Ukrainians he
says I was acting in good faith at all
times as a presidential appointee I
followed the directions of the president
we worked with Giuliani because the
president directed us to do so we had no
desire to set any conditions on the
Ukrainians indeed my personal view was
that the White House meeting and
security assistance should have
proceeded without preconditions of any
kind we were working to overcome the
problems given the facts as they existed
our only interest was to advance
long-standing US policy and support
Ukraine's fragile democracy okay so now
the question becomes with this testimony
with this testimony do the Democrats
have what they need do they have what
they need do they really believe that
they are going to be able to somehow
draw the impeachment rabbit out of this
hat based on sunland saying that there
was a quid pro quo and some of that is
going to depend on the White House
actively not pursuing the dumbest
possible defense and like the one that's
not true maybe I don't know why Trump
thinks that it is more embarrassing for
him to say
yeah there was a quid pro quo but the
quid pro quo is for my concerns about
2016 what's the problem right he was
angry at Mick Mulvaney for saying that
but Mick Mulvaney actually was saying
the actual defence from the White House
I don't know why that's somehow more
embarrassing than him claiming pretty
obviously falsely that there was a no
quid pro quo and that his phone call on
July 25th was perfect
I understand Trump's normal defense
mechanism is that you defend it you
defend at the front line every time
right you never make a strategic retreat
you never reveal your plans right I get
all of that but in this particular case
he's put himself out there on grounds
that are unsustainable and Republicans
are not gonna be able to sustain those
grounds they can easily work within the
grounds that I have suggested and that
the Washington Post's just suggested
again it's not just me the Washington
Post is reporting the actual testimony
of aides the aides are saying that Trump
was mainly obsessed with 2016 it was not
about 2020 and by the way there is
crossover between American interests and
2016 vindictiveness by President Trump
there is crossover there whereas there
is no crossover with regard to Trump
going after Joe Biden specifically
because he wanted Joe Biden out in 2020
right that that is the question okay
coming up we'll talk more about this
plus big democratic debate tonight Pete
Buddha judges surging in both Iowa and
New Hampshire doesn't have a real shot
at the nomination beyond that point
we'll get to that in just one second
first did you know that nearly 1 billion
individuals are affected by sleep apnea
around the world true my dad is one of
them that means that he has to use CPAP
equipment CPAP equipment one of the
great inventions of all time it is
keeping people alive but here's the
problem
cleaning a CPAP machine is a real pain
in the butt well so clean is the world's
first automated CPAP cleaner and
sanitizer so clean kills up to 99.9% of
all CPAP germs and bacteria that can
build up in your mask hose and reservoir
it's easy to use just put the mask in
you close the lady walk away and work
with all popular CPAP machines and masks
so clean uses advanced technology to
sanitize your CPAP equipment with just
the touch of a button it is the safer
healthier way to breathe cleaner and
have a better CPAP experience there's no
reason to have a worse night sleep
breathing in the dirty air from a CPAP
when you can actually get so clean go to
so clean calm right now and you can try
them risk-free for 30 nights even
shipping is free so don't wait go to so
clean calms take advantage with this 30
night risk-free trial and free shipping
again that is so clean
once more so clean calm go check them
out
make sure that your CPAP is clean you
don't wanna breathing in 30 air I mean
this thing's keeping you alive make sure
it's clean so clean calm that's so clean
calm alrighty we'll get to more on
impeachment gate 2019 did Gordon Sumlin
give Democrats what they need today
we'll get to all of that in a sec plus
the democratic debates which are
happening tonight and other big
democratic debate we'll get to that in a
second first if you have not been
listening to Andrew Klay viens fantasy
podcast in other kingdom you're missing
out it's a lot of fun you need to go to
daily wire comm right now and subscribe
to catch up because on Monday November
25th at 7 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific
Andrew and Michael moles will be sitting
down together to discuss the final
season and also to take subscriber
questions live from fans which is really
cool this live event will be free for
everyone to watch on Facebook and
YouTube
only subscribers will be able to ask the
questions at daily wire.com Plus
subscribers exclusively can watch the
entirety of the series or you can listen
free to the newest seasons on Apple
podcasts go check it out
don't miss the another Kingdom live
discussion happening Monday 7 p.m.
Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific by the way if you
are not already a subscriber you're
definitely missing out head on over to
daily wire.com slash subscribe for as
little as 10 bucks a month you get the
articles ad free access to all of our
live broadcasts full show library select
bonus content our exclusive daily wire
applic all sorts of goodies that we are
adding to daily if you choose the new
All Access plan you'll get all of that
plus the legendary leftist Sears tumbler
and our brand-new ask me anything style
discussion feature that allows you to
engage our hosts writers and special
guests on a weekly basis so stop
depriving yourself come join the fun go
do it right now
we are the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
so by Bern New York has a really good
piece of the Washington Examiner talking
specifically about the the accusation
that Trump never should have asked about
Purisima and he says well you know that
that's really questionable he says one
of the most important issues in
president Trump's impeachment offense is
also one of the least explored to what
degree with Trump's concerns about
Ukraine valid it's well documented that
the president fixated on Ukrainian
activity in the 2016 election and on the
Biden's actions in the breeze my matter
Democrats and many in the media dismiss
his concerns as conspiracy theories but
to what extent were those concerns in
fact legitimate if there were even
mostly legitimate Trump defenders could
say look he had a point even if one
thinks he handled the issue
inappropriately the fact is what was
going on in Ukraine was worries him
enough for the u.s. presidents take
notice that would not change minds among
those dead set on impeachment but among
others it would make the case for
impeachment and removal much harder to
make of trumps two concerns 2016
interference and Biden Purisima the 2016
part came first and is the foundation
for trumps later concerns about the
former VP so leave the Biden part for a
later article focus on Ukraine in the
2016 election like this is the part
that's so weird I keep seeing articles
from the mainstream media
suggesting that trumps concerns about
Ukrainian interference in the 2016
election are completely fictitious in
fact you had testimony to that effect
yesterday it was very very weird right
you had people who are suggesting that
Ukraine was was never involved in the
2016 election like for example
Lieutenant Colonel Alexander vinum in
this clip 5 suggested that trumps focus
on 2016 interference by Ukraine was
totally fictitious there was no evidence
to it whatsoever are you aware of any
evidence to support the theory that the
Ukrainian government interfered in the
2016 election congressman I am NOT and
I'm furthermore I would say that this is
a Russian narrative that President Putin
has promoted and are you aware of any
part of the US government its foreign
policy or intelligence apparatus that
supports that theory no I'm not aware of
any you are aware that other parts of
the US government our intelligence
community for example has said
definitively
that it was a Russians who interfered in
the 2016 elections that is correct okay
so here is here's the problem it is true
that the Russians interfered in the 2016
election it is also true that there have
been widely available
public reports from credible sources
like Politico suggest if you find
political credible which I do as a
general matter those reports say Ukraine
was coordinating with a woman in dalek
Sandra Lupo who was a DNC hack in order
to grab information on Paul Manafort
Trump's campaign chairman
so Byron York says during the summer of
2016 candidate Trump was under constant
criticism for being insufficiently
critical of Russian President Vladimir
Putin from Ukraine's perspective Trump's
statements were linked to the presence
of pom anaphora in the Trump campaign
mantle Forbes promote its campaign
chairman in June few Americans knew much
about Manta for who's best known
political efforts were with the Gerald
Ford campaign in 1976 but manna fort
later made millions in Ukraine working
for President Viktor Yanukovych and the
pro-russia Party of Regions trumps
comments on Crimea and Ukraine set off a
strong reaction in Ukraine some
high-ranking members of the Ukrainian
government took to social media in an
attempt to influence as best they could
the u.s. presidential race on Facebook
arsen avakov at that time the Interior
Minister tweeted that Trump was a clown
added the Republican candidate was an
even bigger danger to the US than
terrorism
he said the shameless statement of u.s.
presidential candidate Trump on the
possible recognition of Crimea as Russia
is a diagnosan of a dangerous outcast
and called them dangerous and all the
rest of this okay and at the same time
Ukraine's ambassador to the United
States a person in Valerie celli wrote
an op-ed published in the hill
chaley said Trump's statements on Russia
and Crimea have raised serious concerns
in Kiev and beyond Ukraine his obviously
crane was very very concerned about
Trump and based on Trump's commentary
for a decent reason it seems but the
question is did they then interfere in
the in the actual election cycle hey
because it turns out that the Trump
Ukraine brouhaha shed light on the
activities of a woman named Alexander
chalupa who worked in the Clinton White
House and later with the DNC Sheila's
parents emigrated to the u.s. from
Ukraine she maintained strong ties to
the Ukrainian American diaspora and the
US Embassy in Ukraine according to a
January 2017 article in Politico
Ukrainian efforts to sabotage Trump
backfire that is the best source of
information on her activities
Politico reported that in 2014 chalupa
had a clients interested in the
Ukrainian crisis as part of that she
began looking into mana Forte's
activities in Ukraine
chalupa quote developed a network of
sources in Kiev and Washington
including investigative journalists
government officials and private
intelligence operatives in 2015
chalupa began focusing her research on
him the website reported that chulip
occasionally shared her findings with
officials from the DNC
and the Clinton campaign in March 2016
she went to the Ukrainian Embassy in
Washington and shared her concern with
Politico according to Politico with
ambassador J Leon one of his deputies
Oksana shulie are not long after troupis
spoke again with the DNC and according
to Politico with the DNC's encouragement
chalupa asked embassy staff who tried to
arrange an interview in which then
President Petro poroshenko might discuss
mana Ford's ties to Yanukovych so in
other words it sounds like chalupa on
behalf of the DNC wanted the Ukrainian
government to make a public statement
discussing Trump's campaign manager they
sound familiar
political then added quote Andrei
tillage anko who worked as a political
officer in the Ukrainian embassy under
Shirley are said she instructed him to
help to lube eResearch connections
between Trump mana fort and Russia
Oksana said if I had any information or
new knew other people who did I should
contact chalupa recall to luchenko who
is now a political consultant Kyiv they
were coordinating an investigation with
the Hillary team on Paul Manafort with
Alexander chalupa adding Oksana was
keeping it all quiet but the embassy
worked very closely with chalupa in fact
sources familiar with the effort say
that surely are specifically called
tillage ankle into a meeting with
chalupa tube ride an update on an
American media outlets ongoing
investigation into manna fort Politico
also reported that chalupa quote
discussed the possibility of a
congressional investigation with foreign
policy legislative assistants in the
office of Representative Marcy Kaptur
who co-chairs at the congressional
Ukrainian caucus the investigation
didn't end up happening so is there any
evidence about the CrowdStrike nonsense
no but is there evidence that the
Ukrainians were involved in 2016 yeah
there is there are serious open
questions about that and that's what
Trump is obsessing about even according
to the Washington Post even according to
the Washington Post
so did today's so did today's testimony
change that fundamental intent issue not
really not really right president Trump
suggested so so according to Gordon
someone so this is what he just
testified moments ago he said President
Trump never told
directly that aid was conditioned on the
meetings the only thing we got directly
from Giuliani was that Purisima in 2016
elections were conditioned on the White
House meeting the aide was my own
personal you know guest based on your
analogy two plus two equals four okay
but again assuming that the quid pro quo
is a thing which I am happy to assume
because I think it is true the question
becomes intent is the intent impeachable
here my answer all along has been I am
doubtful that it is and someone has not
yet provided any testimony that changes
that okay so tonight is the next big
democratic debate and the field is just
a mess I mean it is an absolute mess
we've had basically several people
contending at the top of the field there
are four top contenders right now Joe
Biden Bernie Sanders still hanging
around
you've got Elizabeth Warren who is
dropping fast and you've got people to
judge who is climbing fast so it seems
to me that Elizabeth Warren is in a lot
of trouble it also seems to me that the
romance with people who to judge is
likely to peter out here there are some
new national polls out today and they
showed you a Biden actually gaining in
the national polls there's an economist
YouGov poll today and has Joe Biden up
nationally 32 22 over Warren Sanders at
12 boo to judge at 9 according to the
hill Harris poll they came out in the
last couple of days is Biden at 30
Sanders at 18 Warren at 15 boo to judge
at 7 I'm telling you this feels a lot
like 2012 it feels a lot like 2012 on
the Republican side it feels like there
was a front-runner everybody was unhappy
with the front-runner everybody else is
gonna get a chance at the top
everybody's gonna fall invite is gonna
be the nominee if you had to predict it
right now that's what I would suggest
the betting odds aren't reflecting that
they still say that Warren is the
likeliest nominee but I'm not seeing why
that would be the case right now
buta judge is leading by big numbers in
both Iowa and New Hampshire there's a
brand new poll out in New Hampshire that
is devastating for Elizabeth Warren that
is her neighboring state she has to win
hey if a Lizabeth Warren does not win
New Hampshire she does not win the
nomination but according to a new st.
anselm poll people to judge has vaulted
to a 10-point lead over the rest of the
field boo to judge 25 Biden 15 Warren 15
Bernie Sanders 9 now people would
suggest here may be hardest hit is Joe
Biden right because Budaj edge is
stealing sort of moderate support away
from Joe Biden in early caucus states
but that's not correct the reason that's
not correct is because if Elizabeth
Warren does not win in Iowa or New
Hampshire which are super white
super progressive territories how the
hell do you think she's gonna perform in
South Carolina where one black person
supports her two thirds of the
electorate in South Carolina on the
Democratic primary side of the aisle is
black which is why Joe Biden is way up
in South Carolina he continues to be up
19 points in South Carolina he continues
to be up 9 points in Nevada
Budi judge by the way is polling at 7
percent in Nevada so Buddha judge were
to win both Iowa and New Hampshire it's
still unlikely he's the nominee because
he has no minority support as in none
zero zip zilch now Bernie Sanders is
falling out of the race but his support
it seems is not bleeding over to
Elizabeth Warren particularly and
tonight the candidates on the debate
stage Elizabeth Warren because she's
like Buddha judge is in good position
because he is climbing in some of the
important state polls but Elizabeth
Warren is still widely perceived by the
media as the front-runner and she has
opened herself up to every possible
attack every plan that she has proposed
is garbage she's been shifting her plans
repeatedly her wealth tax is nonsense
her she's openly a.m. there are people
on stage who are only going to be able
to make hay by attacking Elizabeth
Warren so I'm talking of course of Cory
Booker who if he has any brains at all
should be going after Elizabeth Warren
on her decision to go against charter
schools that you previously supported
and he's gonna have to do that he's
gonna have to say listen Elizabeth I
know that you're a very very white
person despite your Native American
ancestry but your former support for
school choice which was a good idea
you've now subsumed that in order to win
over college-educated white people in
Iowa and what about people who actually
need a better educational opportunity
for their kids in Newark I did X Y & Z
bright that should be Cory Booker's
attack Kamala Harris should be attacking
Elizabeth Warren on the basis of stolen
a sort of stolen racial valor right the
Como hair should say listen as a black
woman in America I know it's like to be
victimized you claim to be a victim by
claiming Native American heritage and
that is absolutely unsustainable right
there'll be a brutal attack on Elizabeth
Warren tonight Bernie Sanders should
attack Elizabeth Warren saying listen
it's my plan you stole my plan and then
you presented it in the worst stupidest
possible way you lied about the cost of
the plan at least I'm honest you are a
damn liar and she's open herself up to
attack from every possible angle every
possible angle so expect a pretty good
night for Pete boo to judge expect Joe
Biden to continue to be Joe Biden Randi
he's never going to have a
wonderful night he's never gonna have a
horrible night expected Elizabeth Warren
is gonna have to fend off attacks and
she has not proved adept at fending off
those attacks she has not so in the
aftermath of this debate she is the one
most at risk here but if you are
Elizabeth Warren tonight you are nervous
you are very very nervous and you should
be extremely nervous she's the most
vulnerable candidate at the top of the
field right now and as again for the
Buddha judge Search I think that he has
a good ground operation in Iowa he's
getting the glowing media coverage that
was reserved for Elizabeth Warren for
about six weeks ago but the media fall
in love with and then out of love with
candidates extremely quickly watch for
in the next few weeks Elizabeth Warren
before for Peabody judge to be hit with
a spate of stories about how he has
badly governed racial politics in the
city of South Penn right that's where
he's most vulnerable watch for that and
watch for Cory Booker in comel Harris to
go after him on that and watch for Joe
Biden a community skate by so in a
certain way Joe Biden is actually
benefiting from the fact that he is the
actual frontrunner being treated as
though he is not the front-runner it's
actually not a terrible place to be it
means most of the attacks are not going
to be leveled to Joe Biden in fact the
Democrats basically have exhausted their
attacks on Joe Biden what else is there
to say about the guy they've already hit
him on criminal justice reform they've
already hit him on working with
Republicans they've already hit him on
being old like what else is there but
there are brand-new attacks on these
other Democratic candidates every day of
the week so I feel like Joe Biden is
actually in shockingly good shape here
Lincoln shockingly good shape so two
things were true one I was right that
his best day was his first day but also
none of these other candidates are
rising from the rising from the bottom
up to the top it's pretty impressed I'm
for a quick thing I like and then some
things that I hate so things that I like
today so there is a fun kids movie
called abominable that is out it's kind
of fascinating also to look at the
Chinese American politics in this film
so this movie was it was a joint
production by a Chinese production
company an American production company
and it's a dreamworks production it was
obviously meant for release in China the
sort of rosy depiction of China is
pretty it's pretty hilarious at the same
time it really is a fun kid's movie I
took my kids just yet they really
enjoyed it it's really innocent it's
really fun you know I've come around to
the notion that the movies are just not
fun anymore which is why everybody is
going to Marvel movies and superhero
movies and kids movies that's why those
big earners and that the less fun the
movie is the more the critics love it
but this is a really nice sweet film for
kids they're no sucker punches or
anything if you're if you're I have a
kid who's three watch the movie loved it
so if you're if you're interested in a
kids movie taking the kids out to the to
the films tonight then abominable is
definitely a worthy choice
this is impossible I wish dad were here
to see this
yeah mom Beijing is great Oh thing is so
one one of the things that's actually
kind of cool about this home so a lot of
it is about getting it basically it's
about getting a Yeti back to Everest
right it's fantasy film and it's fun
it's a fun it's a fun movie and one of
the kid that the kid who stars in it one
of the kids who stars in it is the
grandson of Tenzing Norgay who was a
nepali indian sherpa mountaineer one of
the first people to climb he summoned it
Mount Everest with Edmund Hillary and so
his grandson actually plays one of the
parts in this in this movie it's kind of
fun and and you know again you're
looking for a fun movie for your kids
tonight this would be one to check out
okay time for a quick thing that I hate
exciting news the ACLU is celebrating
international men's day international
men's day so yesterday was international
men's day was supposed to it was
supposed to sort of signify the problems
that men have and men have a higher
suicide rate for example they have that
they have male health issues the idea
was that it was supposed to celebrate
male contributions to society promote
male role models etc well the ACLU came
out with a tweet that basically tells
you about the status of modern politics
and why we are totally screwed here as
ACL u--'s tweet there is no one way to
be a man men who get their periods are
men men who get pregnant and give birth
are men trans and non-binary men belong
hashtag international men's day I'm
gonna have to ask a question here if
there is such a thing as an
international men's day and an
International Women's Day presumably
there is some distinction between them
explain it really explain define man
define man if you are if you are going
to say that a man can get his period
then I don't know what to tell you
yeah it's obviously your definition is
not biological so if your definition is
a characterization of gender stereotypes
then which gender stereotypes are male
is it aggression is it aggression that
makes a man a man because if so then a
biological female who says that she is a
man but does not have the male
characteristic of aggression is not a
man and by the way men who are
biological men who are not aggressive
are not men like oh you have to set a
standard the problem for folks who keeps
justing that trans and non-binary men
are men if the idea is that you are not
a biological man but you are a man then
you have to have an alternative
definition of man that has some sort of
internal coherence the left has none and
so you end up with this stupid I mean
it's absolute stupidity in the ACLU
blames inaccurate stereotypes for
opposition to biological male athletes
competing in female athletics by the way
I mean the ACLU is completely out of
touch they've lost whatever tenuous
grasp of reality they ever had the ACLU
actually gave a statement last year
suggesting that trans women should be
able to compete as women meaning a
biological male should be able to
compete alongside the women and they
suggest that it was inaccurate
stereotyping to oppose biological male
athletes competing against women as
opposed to you know the basic biological
dichotomy between mammalian males and
females true in every mammalian species
the ACLU at the time treated equal
participation in athletics for
transgender people does not mean an end
to women's sports trans women are women
including women and girls who are
transgender and advocate advances
women's equality and well-being um know
having a biological male like Fallon Fox
fight a biological female does not
advance women's equality and well-being
is just Abdul dating a lady which last I
checked is not only unchivalrous but
also quite dangerous this is pretty I
mean this is just absolute guy it's just
ridiculous it's just ridiculous all the
way through ridiculous but the left is
so focused on changing definitions of
basic biological reality that they end
up in the position of actually taking
the interests of women and making them
completely secondary perfect example
there is a school district in Illinois
that has now decided that you get to go
into the locker room of your gender
decision so if you are a boy and you
decide that you are a girl today you get
to go and undress in the women's locker
room well here's a video of a teenage
girl at one of these schools talking
about the fact that she no longer feels
safe in the bathroom because now their
biological boys walking into the
bathroom who could spot her undressing
this clip 23
my privacy is being invaded as I am a
summer I don't change multiple times
naked in front of the other students in
the locker room I understand that sport
has an obligation to all students okay
well there is no I mean the alternative
that has been suggested in the past to
having you know biological boys dressing
alongside females has been to have like
a separate bathroom for transgender kids
right or to have these transgender kids
address behind a curtain allow the girls
to dress but apparently the privacy
concerns of a woman are no longer
relevant so long as a boy who says he's
a girl is treated as a girl and this is
all insanity it has nothing to do with
reality it has nothing to do with
biology it's it's it's it's just that
there's no description that is
appropriate beyond it is pure insanity
to suggest that this is the case truly
yeah it was amazing I do have to mention
this is pretty amazing so I saw an
argument the other day I've always taken
the position that violet that pronouns
refer to objective biological
characteristics right that it that when
I say male and I say female I mean
biological male and biological female
because there is literally no other
descriptor that fits right and if you
take on the attributes of a male or
female that does not make you a male or
female you have to be biologically male
or biologically a female now for
purposes of identifying for going into a
bathroom what you appear to be
objectively to the outside world will
probably be good enough because
otherwise we're not gonna check
everybody's genitals as we walk into the
bathroom or something or check your
genetics as you walk in the bathroom but
for purposes of saying male and female
we mean biological male biological
female so some dolt
suggested to me well there there look at
the Romance languages there are lots of
Romance languages where the verbiage is
gendered right if you look at Hebrew to
take a non Romance language then the the
verbs are gendered right the announced
are gendered as well so for example the
word for table Shulkin is a male word so
that means that all of the verbs are
male verbs and thus because the language
is gendered why should we say that the
word male applies to a male and not to a
trans male this is the stupidest
argument you could possibly imagine the
fact that the
are gendered objects in language for
grammatical reasons does not mean that
the table is a male nor does it mean
that the male is a table nor does it
mean that a male is not a male there's
no transitive property that applies here
plus the logic here is completely
asinine because you have to assume one
of two things either you assume that the
gendering of objects means that gender
has no actual relevance to terminology
in which case what do you care if I call
a male a male and a female a female
because these words mean nothing anyway
or you have to assume that gender does
have content in which case you're with
me if gender has content then a male is
male and a female is female but the
social left wants to have it both ways
and by both ways I mean they just want
to rewrite the entire doctrine of human
language and human logic in favor of the
asinine ocean that men can have periods
already we'll be back here later today
with two additional hours of content
plus we will be back here tomorrow if
you missed that and we'll recap the
debate for you then i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director pavel white house key
edited by adam simon's audio is mixed by
mike core amina hair and makeup is by
Joshua alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19 an insufferable power-hungry
bureaucrat testifies before Congress the
ACLU celebrates menstruation on
international men's day and the UK's
first gay dad is dating his daughter's
boyfriend but don't worry because the
governor of South Dakota is on meth
check it out on the Michael Nolt show
[Music]